hey everyone in this video i'll talk
about the challenges of analyzing market
data in a traditional environment
and how cme smartstream with google
cloud could help
risk is defined as a situation involving
exposure to danger
when it comes to the topic of risk
trading firms are inherently sensitive
especially in current times where global
systems are all being impacted from
market volatility
they manage risk by collecting signals
from a diverse set of data points and
interpreting them to make timely
business
decisions one key source of these data
points is cme smartstream
which delivers a real-time feed of
financial and commodity market data
that traders can use as an input to
inform a risk management strategy
first in introduction to cme group cme
group runs exchanges where futures
contracts are traded
for example a corn futures contract
guarantees a farmer that at harvest time
they'll get a certain amount of money
for their corn
and guarantees a processing plant that
they'll get a certain amount of corn for
their money
the contract price is the price of
certainty
these contracts work the same way for
corn oil or even stock
to get indications of risk trading firms
working for the parties constantly
monitor live
contract prices to do so exchanges
traditionally send each change in a
contract's price
to a trading firm's data center
requiring significant resources for data
storage and analytics
with cme smartstream that same price
data is delivered in real time to
trading firms cloud resources
we selected three personas that care
about the firm's overall risk
a risk manager an infrastructure
engineer and a data scientist
let's take a look at each role first
the risk manager volatility and
information asymmetry injects
uncertainty into the firm's decision
process
timely standardized market data can help
but the traditional methods for
receiving such data are oftentimes
costly and complex in contrast google
cloud attaches directly to cme
smartstream to store large data sets in
our bigquery backend
and allow analysis through a plethora of
options including standard sql
when combined risk managers easily get
the visualizations they need
while paying for only the resources they
use and as a result
they're afforded a real-time view of
exposure that can help them adjust
positions
and mitigate risk promptly when
necessary
next let's take a look at the data
scientists world for trading firms this
area is riddled with complexity
you've got to acquire ingest explore and
analyze the data
all before you can take action but
google cloud allows data scientists
to retrieve cme smart stream data
transform it via data flow and store it
in bigtable or bigquery
then the data scientists can use google
cloud's automl platform
to train and deploy models that predict
whether a contract price will move up or
down
as you can see she can store analyze and
visualize
results with tools that scale deploy and
adapt in real time
finally let's look at this from the
infrastructure engineer's perspective
one of the big problems many firms face
is that inbound financial data traverses
the public internet or a costly private
line before ingestion
as an alternative google cloud offers
managed networking functionality
regionally and globally
this way the infrastructure engineer can
connect the on-prem or remote resources
to google cloud without needing to
replicate connectivity or administrative
policies
in each region additionally trading
firms struggle with keeping on-prem or
even cloud resources
up and running as our demo shows this
problem can be managed simply and
effectively
[Music]
we start by leveraging terraform to
script the deployment of our
microservices architecture
this architecture allows us to
containerize our application components
while making it easier to support ci cd
pipelines
terraform enables the automation of
infrastructure making infrastructure
easily auditable for any governance need
and that's it in this demo we showed you
how risk managers
data scientists and infrastructure
engineers can easily manage risk in the
cloud
using real-time market data we hope you
found it useful
for more about everything we've talked
about check out the links in the
description below
and don't forget to subscribe to our
google cloud youtube channel for more
great content